[موسيقى]
طب بالبدايه انا درست تصوير فوتوغرافي
بخارج لبنان وكنت تصور من عمر العشر سنين
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
بسنه 2010 اول ما لقيت ارشيف ايميل بولس
بالباترون من هون بلشت الفكره تبعي انه
يبلش جمع صور واشتغل على ارشيف الصور
اللبناني
[موسيقى]
اشتغلنا على ارشيفات بلبنان اشتغلنا على
ارشيفات بتركيا جبنا كل الارشيف الصور
والوسائط يلي بتخص الارشيف العثمانيه اللي
كانت تخص لبنان واشتغلنا اكثر كمان على
الارشيفات يلي بتخص الدول العربيه كمان
نحن حديث هلا تقريبا صرنا مجمعين حوالين
مليون صوره
عملنا دورات برا لبنان عليهم تعلمنا كيف
بيترمم الصور تعلمنا كيف كل صوره بدك
تعالجيها بطريقه وحده نيجاتيف الو طريقه
يعني الصوره السلبيه الى طريقه الصوره
الورقيه الى طريقه
في عنا هون مثلا صوره لساحه الشهداء
1884 عنا 85 عنا 1890
هدول هيدا التقى بالارشيف العثماني
باسطنبول
[موسيقى]
صوره بانوراما بيروت لبيروت 1915 مثلا
في عنا كمان محطات سكه الحديد ببيروت عنا
خرايط بيروت
معموله بال 1908 في عنا خرايط من 1525
مثلا
يعني هيدي قلعه بيروت هون
قال لي كانت موجوده قريبه على بور بيروت
هيدي بالالفين الصوره ماخوذه وهذه 885
هيدي ما بقى موجود اثر منها لا اثر كتير
صغير موجود بقلب بسوق بيروت حاليا
الهاودي كان كل صوره على قفاها يجي اسم
المصور
في عنا مثلا هون عنا هون في عنا
في عنا جدعان في عنا صابونجي
مثلا البومفيس حكينا عنه
وهون كمان في اول صوره فوق هيدي زياده
الامبراطور الالماني على على بيروت
[موسيقى]
هون في عنا شغله كتير مهمه العالم ما كثير
بتعرفها انه بال 1890 كان في شيء اسمه
صوره ثلاثيه الابعاد هيدي المكنه كنا
نستعملها وهوده صور
قزاز معمولين
فيهم 3 دي يعني ثلاثيه الابعاد اذا بتحطها
على عينك لهيدي وبتحط الصوره بقلبها بتقدر
تقشعها
[موسيقى]
وان الصورتين هون كتير مهمين ماخودين بسنه
1920 لجبران خليل جبران يلي كانوا ماخودين
بنيويورك هودي
[موسيقى]
بالباترون ما كان في غيره ابدا بمنطقه
البترون
بنته دلتني على على المكان صار كان مهجور
من حوالي لاخر الثمانينات هو كان في يصور
فيه وتركوا
وتوفى تقريبا
[موسيقى]
بعده موجود
اوكي وهدول كمان قسم من الصور بس اكيد
الوضع يلي الماساوي يلي صار فيهم نحنا يلي
بيتاخدوا اخدناهم معنا وصاروا عنا كلياتهم
هذول من الصغير هذا نيجاتيف
[موسيقى]
التقى حوالي 80 الف نيجاتيف